[Music]
[Applause]
first of all let me thank America for
its modified tEDGlobal for putting this
conference together and this conference
is going to rank as the most important
in the beginning of the 21st century
think African governments will put
together a conference like this they
think we you will put together a
conference like this even before they do
that do ask for foreign aid I will also
would like to pay homage and honor to
the TED Fellows June arooga James chica
wati Andrea and the other TED Fellows I
call them the cheetah generation the
cheetah generation is a new breed of
Africans who know nonsense about
corruption they understand what
accountability and democracy is they're
not going to wait for government to do
things for them that's the cheetah
generation an Africa salvation rests on
the backs of these cheaters
in contrast of course we have the hippo
generation
the hippo generation at the ruling
Elysee
they are stuck in their intellectual
patch complaining about colonialism and
imperialism they wouldn't move one foot
you ask them to reform the economies
they are not gonna reform it because
they benefit from the rotten status quo
now there are a lot of Africans were
very angry angry at a condition of
Africa now we're talking about a
continent which is not poor that is rich
in mineral resources natural mineral
resources but the mineral wealth of
Africa is not be utilized to lift its
people out of poverty that's what makes
a lot of Africans very angry and in a
way never gets more than a tragedy more
ways than one
there's another enduring tragedy and
that tragedies there are so many people
so many governments so many
organizations who want to help the
people in Africa they don't understand
now we're not saying on how Africa
helping Africa is noble but helping
Africa has been turned into a fear of
the absurd it's like the blind leading
the clueless there are certain things
that we need to recognize Africa's
begging bowl leaks did you know that 40
percent of the world created in Africa
is not here invested here in Africa
sticking out of Africa that's what a
World Bank says lot of Africa's begging
bowl it leaks horribly there are people
who think that we should pour more money
more aid into this bowl which leaks what
are the leakages corruption alone costs
Africa 148 billion dollars a year
yeah put that aside capital flight out
of Africa eighty billion a year put that
aside let's take food input every year
Africa spends twenty billion dollars to
import food just added up all these
messages that's far more than the fifty
billion twenty Blair wants to raise for
Africa now back in the 1960s Africa not
only fed itself it also exported food
not anymore
we know that something has gone
fundamentally wrong you know it I know
it
but let's not waste our time talking
about these mistakes because we spent
all day here let's move on and flip over
to the next chapter and that's what this
conference is all about the next chapter
the next chapter begins with first of
all asking us of this fundamental
question whom do we want to help in
Africa there's the people and then
there's the government or leaders now
the speaker before me that previous
speaker before me it was Mohammed
indicated that we've had abysmal
leadership in Africa that
characterization in my view is even more
charitable
I belong to an internet discussion forum
an african internet discussion forum and
Azzam i said since 1960 we've had
exactly two hundred and four African
heads of state since 1960 and I asked
them to name me just 20 good leaders
just 20 good leaders maybe what you may
want to take this you know leadership
challenges you know yourself ask them to
name it just drinking everybody
mentioned Nelson Mandela
of course Kwame Nkrumah Herrera Kenyatta
somebody mentioned Idi Amin I let that
pass point is they couldn't go beyond 15
even if they had been able to name me 20
what is Italia 20 out of 204 means that
the majority the vast majority of the
African leaders failed their people and
if you look at them the slave of the
post-colonial leaders an assortment of
military foo-foo heads Swiss bank
socialists crocodile liberators vampire
elite Park revolutionaries
now this leadership is a far cry from
the traditional leaders that Africans
have known for centuries the second
false premise that we make when we're
trying to help Africa is that sometimes
we think that there is something called
a government in Africa that cares about
its people serves the interests of the
people and represents the people there
is one particular quote and it's what of
the chief one says that he really sort
of got two problems rats and the
government what you and I understand as
a government doesn't exist in many
African countries right what would what
we call our governments our vampire
states vampires is because these suck
the economic vitality out of their
people government is the problem in
Africa a vampire state is a government
which is me hijacked by a phalanx of
bandits and crooks who use the
instruments of state power to enrich
themselves their cronies and tribesmen
and exclude everybody else the richest
people in Africa are heads of state and
ministers and quite often the chief
bandit is the head of state himself
where did they get the money by creating
wealth no by retinyl of the backs of
their sovereign people
that's not wealth creation is worth
redistribution the third fundamental
issue that we have to recognize is that
if we want to help the African people we
must know where the African people are
taking a second is honoring an African
economy can be broken up into three
sectors there is the modern sector
there is the informal sector and the
traditional sector the morning sector is
the abode of the elites is the seat of
government may African countries the
modern sector is lost is dysfunctional
it is a meretricious Fandango of
imported citizens which they release
themselves don't understand that is the
source of many of Africa's problems
where the struggles for political power
emanate and in spillover on today in
football and the traditional sector
framing innocent lives now the morning
sector of course is where a lot of the
development aid and resources went into
more than 80% of Ivory Coast's
development went into the modern sector
the other sectors they a formal and the
traditional sector of where you find the
majority of the African people the real
people in Africa that's where you find
them now obviously makes common sense
that if you want to help the people you
go where the people are but that's not
what we did it's one of what we
neglected no more the informal and the
traditional sectors then traditional
that is where Africa positions is
agriculture which is one of the reasons
why I forget can't feed itself and
that's why it must import food all right
you cannot develop Africa by ignoring
the informal any traditional sectors and
it can't develop the informal and the
traditional circus without an
operational understanding of are these
two sectors work these two sectors let
me describe you have their own
indigenous institutions first one is the
political system
traditionally Africans keep government's
the hit torini
if you look into your traditional
systems Africans organize the states in
two types the first one belonged to
those ethnic societies who believed that
the state was necessarily tyrannous so
they don't want to have anything to do
with any centralized Authority these
societies are the ebo they somali they
Kikuyus for example they have no chiefs
the other ethnic groups which did have
Chiefs make sure that the surrounded
achieves with councils upon councils
upon councils to prevent them from
abusing their power in a society not
reached for example the chief cannot
make any decision without a concurrence
of the council of elders without a
council the chief can pass any law and
if the chief doesn't govern according to
the will of the people he will move if
not the people will abandon the chief go
somewhere else instead of set up a new
settlement and even if you look in
ancient African empires they were all
organized around one particular
principle the confederacy principle
which is characterized by a great deal
of devolution of authority
decentralization of power now this is
what I've described to you this is part
of Africa's indigenous political
heritage now compare that to the modern
systems the ruling elites established
upon Africa on Africa to the total
farcry in the economic system in
traditional Africa the means of
production is privately owned
so owned by extended families see in the
West the basic economic and social unit
is the individual the American we say I
am because I am and I can damn well do
anything I want anytime the accent is on
the eye in Africa the African see I am
because we are
the weconnect connotes community the
extended family system textured a family
system proves its resources together
their own farms they decide what to do
what to produce they don't take any
orders from their chiefs they decide
what to do when they produce your crops
this Aldo surplice on marketplaces when
they make a profit it is theirs to keep
not for the chief to sequester it from
them so in a nutshell what we had in
traditional Africa was a free market
system
there were markets in Africa before the
colonialist of food on the continent
Timbuktu was one big big market town can
do szeliga they were all there even if
you go to West Africa
you notice that market activity in West
Africa has always been dominated by
women so it's quite appropriate that
this section is called a marketplace the
market is not alien to Africa what
African practice was a different form of
capitalism but then after independence
all of a sudden markets
capitalism became became a Western
institution and the leader said Africans
were ready for socialism nonsense and
even then what kind of socialism did
they practice the socialism that the
practice was a peculiar form of Swiss
bank socialism which allowed a head of
states and their ministers to written
plan Africa's that deposits the
Treasuries for deposit in Switzerland
that is not a kind of system Africans
that know for centuries what do we do
now go back to Africa's indigenous
institutions and this is where we charge
the Cheetahs to go into the informal
sectors the traditional sectors that's
where you find the African people and I
like to show you a quick little video
about the informal sector but the
boatbuilding that are myself trying to
mobilize Africans in the Diaspora to
invest in could you please show that
[Applause]
mary-jane get to a point where I'm at
[Music]
[Applause]
into something which so that oppression
will be made more efficient now it is
not just the informal sector there is
also traditional medicine eighty percent
of Africans still rely on traditional
medicine totally collapse now this is an
area and we said at rover had trauma
threats of work in the traditional
medicine major this is where we need to
mobilize Africans in the Diaspora
especially to invest in this we also
need to mobilize South Africans in the
Diaspora not only to go into the
traditional sectors also but to go into
agriculture and also to instigate change
from within we were able to mobilize
Ganesh in a diaspora to instigate change
in Ghana and bring about democracy in
Ghana and I know that with the Cheetahs
we can take Africa back one village at a
time thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]